here it is ladies and gentlemen from
cnbc
the recession will hit in the first half
of 2023 and the dow is headed lower cnbc
cfo survey so they asked 22 cfos
c-suite-level dudes from like i think
they're fortune 500 companies and they
all basically said oh we're doomed and
they blamed the fed that was one of the
interesting things that they said the
federal reserve is a huge risk factor
for us so uh it's gonna get bad
we also have inflation
bide inflation says the post-millennial
inflation hits 41-year high as gas and
food prices soar that's right you know
it i don't need to tell it to you gas
prices have hit a five dollar national
average after rapid rise
so here's what what we're seeing august
food shortages
gas prices are going to be through the
roof i think they're saying it's going
to be six to seven dollars nationwide so
california will be over 10 bucks that's
for sure
and diesel shortages was one of the
things that i'm seeing across the board
when that happens everything else is
going to go up it's going to get way
worse and then here's the best part the
fall harvest is going to be depleted
because we had no fertilizer in the
springtime because of the war with
russia and ukraine so we're going to be
screwed i'll just say all of that stuff
in and of itself right
it's falling apart the world is and then
you see the political stuff with january
6 and i'm just like this country's
falling apart politically everything's
just crumbling how are you guys doing
we attacked as a culture we attacked our
the foundations of our country we
attacked our cultural foundations we
completely
destroyed what we were built upon
ideologically and now we are suffering
the price of that we're suffering the
fallout from that well it didn't take a
genius to see what was going to happen
ever since the beginning of covid you
could see the government intervening in
the private market shutting it down
allowing their friends to be open and
destroying any kind of possibility for
upward economic mobility it has been
destroyed people's futures have been
destroyed and these are the consequences
we are paying for these lockdowns for
these politicians that thought that they
could control every aspect of your
existence because you let them control
it well so let's start with this gas
real quick because we were getting into
this a little bit
uh
i was driving my tesla today oh and um i
was so confused why everybody looked so
angry at the gas station and i just
shook my head and it's like
silly people just get an electric car
it's only 60 grand did you wave did you
wave at them as you were driving by them
i honked and i yelled at them good and i
said you
you need to buy electric cars and the
guy you're back i can't afford electric
cars like that's an excuse you can
afford a hundred bucks for a gallon of
gas you can afford electric cars
check this out i really think that's
what they want so fracking for instance
used to be
it was not profitable because the cost
of fracking was higher than the amount
of energy you'd get out from it once
fuel started reaching a certain level
all of a sudden it was like okay now
fracking makes sense this is what's
going to happen
if you're already spending 100 bucks to
fill up your your car's gas tank you're
going to be like well what's 300 bucks
for
you know a loan an electric car
might as well just do that i guess it's
gonna be cheaper the problem ultimately
you can't get electric cars because
everybody's trying to get it all at once
in the supply chain disruption and
there's not enough batteries there's not
enough raw materials there's there's not
enough supply to meet the demand and uh
again
the new york post just released an
article detailing a lot of the price
rises they're talking about how
restaurants went up nine percent uh when
it comes to prices groceries 11.9
electricity 12
new cars and trucks 12.6 these are the
official numbers the the real life
numbers are probably a lot higher ground
beef 13.6 percent chicken 17.4
airfare 37.8 percent gas 48
fuel 170 i'll i'll tell you where i'm
really feeling those gas prices man so
you know when we were we were trying to
book a private plan a private jet to
austin it was it was four thousand
dollars round trip i'm sorry
no caviar prices no no hold on
you you you need to like
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
okay i i didn't finish okay
at 24 was fine
but now it's been six months fifty five
thousand dollars for a round-trip flight
oh well fifty-five is just too much i
mean twenty-five thousand and that just
crosses the line
how are you
hold on but i'm dead serious i was
talking alex jones about it and i was
like how are these people like i hear
all these stories like amber heard just
flowing on a private plane and he was
just telling me he's like well you know
look this was back in november he's like
he's like usually it's around like
twenty five thousand dollars or find a
private plane like austin or something
and i was like wow that really is
expensive that's insane i was like we'll
fly commercial it's a couple hundred
bucks and then we were looking at
flights again because we have there's
like apps that track it 55 000 so it
doubled that's that's that's the fuel
shortage in the fuel increases
yeah that's crazy the other thing too is
that we are being pushed into this
electric vehicle economy
because supposedly it's more sustainable
but there have not been any discussions
about how the battery the materials and
the batteries are mined how those things
are disposed of it's not actually
necessarily more sustainable once you
take all of those things into
consideration
just like with the plastic bag thing in
new york where they took away all the
plastic bags and then they started
replacing them with paper and cloth
that's not actually more sustainable it
costs more to transmit those things you
know to transport those things costs
more to make them all of this stuff and
this is you know this is what they want
they want to destroy us and as many
times as biden keeps every time he says
that they want to remake the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out
it's just a complete and total lie they
want to remake the economy from the top
down by forcing us all to conform to
whatever bizarre ideas that they have
that aren't actually doing the thing
they think it is doing so let me let me
ask you guys you're uh uh
libby are you you're okay with saying
what you're based out of right yeah i
live in new york how how what's it been
like i mean have the price increase has
been noticeable no not particularly
there have been noticeable price
increases in new york but not as much as
other places because we were already
paying a premium for everything
so um but i will say
i will say
um
so they haven't been recently more
noticeable they were very noticeable six
months ago so it had been like i'd pay
45 for a bag of normal groceries and
then a week later it was like you know
50 and it just kept going up now we've
sort of leveled off but i also buy way
different stuff than i used to like um i
used to make
my son really likes like the support
katsu style pork chops that i make um
i used to make them once a week and now
i make them more like once a month i'll
buy like one
meat thing that and we'll have that once
a week and that's pretty much it so
that is different there have been a lot
of different like i've been changing how
i buy things and the gas is ridiculous
what about you andy
well my i i'm just thinking about how
how hard the working class must be
taking us i think for people who are
uh have the benefit of working in
relatively secure
type of works like journalism or such
where you have that security you're
above a certain income and you don't
necessarily feel these percentage
increases or if you do you see it it
doesn't impact you as much as those who
are
living
um paycheck to paycheck and i i didn't i
wasn't aware of these numbers until you
pulled them um into you you mentioned it
here and it's so shocking because it's
like
i don't know how
a working family with children can
survive
with those type of cost increases
and it's a it's an issue that's
affecting all of the world i mean the
if you turn into the the uk press the uh
increases in the uh energy costs
especially
um
the people are feeling it really there
in france they haven't recently had
their presidential elections and that
was the the the cost of living was like
they keep voting
they deserve nothing but contempt
no i mean it like they rioted after you
know uh they they attacks on petrol
uh was put in and this is this is under
macro the yellow vest stuff yeah and
they protest they riot for 18 months and
then they're like we have to vote for
him again it's like okay
you get what you get what you vote for
dude i'm not gonna i'm not gonna no
empathy there
he they voted for him again
they did but i mean they
they were giving them the there are only
two options it's kind of like i don't
know
can you really blame
half of america now for suffering
because of the current administration we
have oh no i mean like the people who
voted for le pen i'm like man that sucks
you know the people who look the
majority of people who voted for these
people i'm just like
what do you want me to say about it but
if one can complain what you vote for
man but if i'm gonna play devil's
advocate a little bit i'm wondering how
would you all respond then let's say to
the argument that
look all over the world uh countries and
societies are experiencing increa
increases across the board because of
the result of the pandemic and you
cannot blame this on the current head of
state yeah so i was looking at a chart
that shows the economy in wages wage
growth and inflation under donald trump
during the pandemic and then under joe
biden and for some reason a month after
joe biden becomes inaugurated wages
collapse
and start receding and inflation
skyrockets
and then i hear from people they're like
well that's because what we're seeing
now is the result of what donald trump
did and i'm like so hold on so you're
saying
that nine months of policy
so the the policy from nine months prior
to the inauguration
that trump did and the and the governors
resulted in a massive spike in inflation
and wages collapsing nine months later
is that that's what they're saying
they're saying what trump did during the
pandemic resulted in this slide okay
well joe biden's had a year and a half
and it's only gotten worse so that means
joe biden's cleared those nine months he
should have done something when he got
in to reverse what trump was doing wrong
no the reality is under trump even in
the pandemic there was some it was
relatively stagnant growth was there
around two to three percent things got
really bad when governor shut everything
down but inflation was not this high
even with the spending now under joe
biden nine months later where where is
the change where where is the recovery
it's not there they're lying they're
making it up so inflation so just really
quickly andy i would also answer you
specifically by talking about the us
dollar being the world reserve currency
it's the petro dollar so what happens
here absolutely matters and affects the
entire world especially when you have
when you have the u.s federal reserve
controlling the supply of the dollars
and when it's bailing out some of the
richest most powerful institutions in
this country it screws everyone else
over because it puts so much of that
money out there in the world market that
it devalues the purchasing power of the
dollar for the people who hold it
because it's literally being printed out
of thin air and if you look at the
purchasing power of the dollar it
continues to go down dramatically not
just within the last year two years
three years we're talking about decades
of the dollar being deliberately
destroyed and to me all of this is done
on purpose as a part of the great reset
where they're going to be building back
better after destroying the old system
and i think what we're seeing right now
is being done deliberately and it's
dangerous and it's affecting us but more
importantly it's going to be affecting
the world even more it is being done
deliberately and it's being done
deliberately in order to change society
and remake it into something that the
democrats believe will be better and
what they don't understand is that they
haven't come up with anything better
sustainable energy
renewables they're not better they're
not ready they cannot bear the brunt of
our industrial
american nation um
neither can evs neither can any of this
stuff and instead of
dealing with
inflation instead of dealing with
economic issues they have been reversing
um you know trying to make changes in
society like the first day joe biden was
in office he basically eliminated
women you know from like civil rights um
and has proceeded to do that so their
biggest concerns are uh
an ideology that very few people but the
elites agree with if they even agree
with it a lot at all if they're not just
putting it on and changing the economy
to you know benefit themselves and their
friends and their their ideology that's
all it is it's a trash way of of running
this country maybe i'm not youth i don't
think it's intentional i think it's just
incompetence you think it's just i think
i used to think it was incompetence
that's the thing i used to think it was
incompetence and now now i think they
are intentionally trying to destroy the
country because they hate our founding
and they hate what we came from they
hate our culture and they hate america
that's not what i think i definitely
hear you on that point but i don't think
you need to go that far it is
intentional because they said it was joe
biden specifically said he wanted to
take climate change seriously the
democrats said they want to take climate
change seriously greta tuneburg said how
dare you and so joe biden gets elected
and he says let's shut down oil and gas
leases let's let's shut down keystone
which caused rampant speculation and
then you see this major
fluctuation in wages inflation all of
these things
it's not all joe biden's fault but if
someone comes in and says i'm gonna save
the environment and then all of a sudden
gas spikes through the roof and then
they enacted policies to make it harder
i'm like well yeah that is them doing it
they said they were going to do it they
said that's why they're going to do it
so i would say
i'm not saying they want the economy to
be on fire
but
i'll say this we know they don't want
you driving cars they've said that we
know they don't want you flying in
planes they've said that we know they
don't like farting cows they literally
did say that so when they enact policies
that make it harder for you to drive i'm
like well they said they wanted this if
the end result is the economy is bad i
can't definitively prove that's what
they wanted
but if people can't drive the economy
will get bad so it is the result of what
they've been trying to do why why do you
think what drives americans to the
streets in protest is not economic
crisis but things cultural issues such
as over guns abortion black lives matter
or protesting the right well all of
those things uh you have to be really
stupid to want to protest right so guns
for instance i saw uh meme you know i
love the memes on facebook and it said
to sell a taco in texas you've gotta get
a permit you've gotta pay a fee
only use certain ingredients import them
and have them regulated well it's like a
huge list it's like how to buy an
assault rifle bring your id walk in fill
out a form have as many guns as you want
and i'm just like okay to buy an assault
rifle you have to have to do a
background check from the atf the fbi
you got a fingerprinted by a sheriff's
department whole process can take right
now they're estimating about six months
but it could be taking a year
considering they're they're a little
backed up these are called nfa items so
the people that are going out going no
assault rifles like they have no idea
what they're talking about the people
that are going out and protesting
abortion have no idea what they're
talking about we have someone on this
show a progressive and he could not tell
us what he really thought about abortion
because he just kept saying it's the
woman's choice the woman's choice and he
didn't know any of these news stories he
didn't know about kathy tran in virginia
wanting abortion at nine months and
things like that and then what was the
other one other thing you mentioned oh
the right well yeah when you watch
nothing but cnn and they're like
insurrection and you hear aoc going he
pounded on my door and went where is he
you are completely brainwashed in a cult
so of course you're angry and frustrated
because they keep just beating you over
the head with this craziness meanwhile
you have people who are associated with
the quote unquote right which includes
post liberals moderates libertarians
conservatives who are like i actually
read the news about guns and oh i
understand it's a nuanced issue it's
hard to solve i actually read the news
on the abortion stuff yeah those people
are crazy aren't they then you actually
see antifa and here's what i won't get i
don't understand why the right
isn't marching in protest against all of
the waves of destruction caused by
antifa the 529 insurrection when when
leftists set fire and tried to raise st
john's church when they set fire to a
white house guard post when they tried
to actually break down the fencing of
the white house and the president was
forced into a bunker and the right what
are they doing they're going january 6
is dumb and i'm like they're sitting
here screaming january 6 in your face
and you're saying nothing but yeah well
you're dumb you'd think the right would
be like may 29th may 29th over and over
and over again and say let's play that
game the right never does all they do is
respond to whatever this left is doing
that's because the right for so long has
been completely overtaken with this idea
of the live and let live culture like
okay you want to do whatever your thing
is do it in your own house you know you
don't have to talk about it we don't
have to deal with it publicly that's all
fine
we'll let it we'll let those crazy
people do whatever they want um and so
they there's no real conservative
culture of an intentional protesting
type of pushback we're not seeing that i
think we're starting to see that a
little bit more i think we're starting
to see that bubble up and you know i've
only just become aware of organizations
that are intentionally trying to do
stuff like that
um but it's new i mean conservatives
need to create a culture of demanding
their rights and of demanding justice it
it hasn't existed
it hasn't existed up until this point it
just hasn't existed yeah i think that
people have you ever had that problem
where you eat a bunch of sugar and then
like you have no energy after that
you're just exhausted for like a day or
two days or something i think people are
living in that state right now and
they're just
a lot of people are unmotivated to get
up and to scream it starvation will make
people crazy that's something like we
talk about the left are motivated to
organize and mobilize over and over and
over
yeah including over non-issues i think
maybe uh and hoaxes
when people are on psychoactives like
adderall and stuff that
their emotions are very flippant and
they can be pushed with like uh
spectacle really easily so a burning
building or a guy getting punched can
make people like become enraged and go
do whatever the news anchor tells them
to do especially when they're on
psychoactives
um i think that's what part of the
population is coming from the crazy
thing is we know that a lot of these
assassinations thought history have been
just really deranged people i mean what
was it hinckley just got released right
now you've got the 9-1-1 call being
released about the guy who went to
assassinate kavanaugh and he just he's
on the phone saying i need help i need
psychiatric help something's wrong like
the dude was just
was nuts and so these people turn on the
tv and what do they see they say chuck
schumer going like you will pay the
price and he's like yes yes then he sees
the address posted by ruth sent us and
he's like yes yes then he buys a plane
ticket gets the weapons shows up and
then fortunately this guy turned himself
in that's why i don't like like um
elizabeth warren would use this flowery
rhetoric we need to fight to get our
something then fight and fight but to
the people on psychoactives what they're
hearing is i need to fight and they
really think they got to go fight
somebody and then they they
i mean they're out literally out of
their mind yo did you guys i i heard uh
uh no good the quartering got swatted
again is that is that and rocato believe
i think he got swatted while he was
doing that but both of them i think at
the same time that's what i heard they
both got swat at the same time i think
so see i'm telling you man everything's
just imploding like
so here's here's what i was saying the
other day
if the federal government will not
enforce the law these people shook up to
kavanaugh's house they won't do it then
someone actually tries to kill the guy
and they still won't enforce the law
against these protesters that is them
outright saying we do not protect you we
will not protect you and in all in all
reality genseki encouraged them to do it
yep they're outright saying we are the
ones against you like the protesters in
the federal law enforcement effectively
the same thing as far as i'm concerned
then
you have the will the unwillingness to
actually enforce the law or i mean
they're probably happy it's happening i
can only imagine you have the swattings
against us now the quartering raketa and
other people
and they say we can't stop it
so if you can't do anything to protect
us and you won't enforce the law to
those that seek to do us harm
how is there a country at all this is an
awkward tyranny yes we were talking
about this yesterday that that's exactly
what it is it's law-abiding citizens
being held to account and everyone else
gets to do as they please and if you
notice also the
the powers that be they protect the
leftist protesters but they come after
the conservative ones i i'll never
forget in lansing michigan i'm pretty
sure it was lansing early on in the
pandemic i think it was in april you had
a bunch of people whose businesses had
been shut down not the casino casino
owners they were fine not the liquor
store owners they were fine but gretchen
whitmer had shut down all of these
businesses
nail shops and hair shops and like
whatever else so all of these people
went to lansing they protested at the
state house there they were called white
supremacists they were dragged out of
there you know all of these things when
conservatives protest for their rights
to just exist they're the ones who are
vilified they're the ones who are taken
out just like the you know the j6 people
how many people did they take down in
that and it's all being tried with
misdemeanors how long have they spent in
jail no trial you know and last week you
had joe biden saying that none of our
rights
none of our rights are absolute and you
can see that his doj means it because
these people don't get a speedy trial
right we have a right to a speedy trial
we have a right to reasonable bail these
people aren't getting that joe biden
means it when he says that our rights
are not absolute he's 100 on that that's
why i say
we've probably been in civil war for you
know for a while now
people just don't recognize it because
they expect warfare to stay the same and
i blame fallout the fallout franchise
naturally because ron perlman keeps
telling us that war never changes but
war actually changes quite a bit
um that's why there's multiple
generations of there's different
generations of warfare and strategies
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there